[Music]
four down by the sea yeah it's beautiful
look at those mountains yeah it is
absolutely gorgeous you know it I'm so
excited about America getting this I
really do think this is gonna be great
for us this is an amazingly beautiful
land you have and for America to own it
for it to be part of America is very
exciting
we're we now bébé thanks the old place
the old place you're the expert on
Greenland what is this building right
here
it's everything's the old Vista deal
with that that is a famous Church is it
not yes yes Hospital it's a hospital
yeah okay let's just assume everything's
old do people often swim here it's very
cold though right cold but this it's
good for the body it's not good for the
testicles
my shoulder to pleasure myself I'd need
to get up here
I got your fast baby tell me what is
that marking mean on top of that roof
c11 it's the mocking from the World War
to World War two yeah so the helicopter
squishy which time they were in also the
planes coming in if they saw c11 they
could know which part of yeah no they
come along in the Korean War
okay I gotcha some guy do together so in
World War two when line scooters were on
their way over in Germany to attack they
could tell but to see 11 volts happening
this is a famous statue what's going on
in here
it's some other food what is the story
here
this is seize the mud left fatigued and
she don't like trash in the sea so in
this trash in the sea
yeah tells all the creatures to come
down to her I see an interspecies orgy
bear on woman on dude action that's what
I'm getting it is a carp down here it's
really been excluded from the pond
probably more interested after he sees
this statue say what you were gonna take
me someplace what's the idea to my face
seriously are you inviting me to your
house yeah that's so nice oh wow this is
beautiful
we're about to enjoy a true Greenlandic
meal describe these dishes to me if you
will what do we have here this is just
lamb that's lamb there's a Smith back
what is that you asking
that's whale skin Oh miss you fat from a
seal did it go in for a liposuction they
took the fat and the seal then went on
to date other seals yeah why not
just right here
drei seal yeah if I were to throw that
into a bathtub with a seal just emerge
okay silly question I suppose it's just
how my imagination works is it oh these
are - yeah
I thought this was a freak of nature it
looked to me like you had accidentally
killed one of the only two-headed fish
in the world you want some lamb okay
just go your lamb want a nice slice of
seal fat it's really tough to cut how do
you fingers yeah I'm not getting in
there with my fingers that seal fat can
you do it I'm scared it's moving and
it's doing things God seal ever try a
salad this is a true true Greenlandic
meal why are you shaking your head no I
can't eat that much well you don't have
to eat it all when this country becomes
part of America will be wasting a lot of
food that's what we do in America we
throw food away do you mind if I say a
prayer your God may Greenland soon
become part of the United States whether
they want to or not
[Applause]
tell me what are some of the traditions
of an Greenlandic meal what kinds of
things are discussed I want to fit right
in seamlessly deliver the weather yeah
okay let me guess how that goes
pretty cold out there huh kids give it a
good day at school today what'd you
learn nothing
you're gonna love America what did you
study in school today math do you like
math yeah I had a hard time too when I
couldn't figure out math I became very
angry and frustrated many other children
would beat me with sticks very painful
part of my why are you guys laughing at
that that's not funny
that was beat no no that's not funny
when I struggled with math as a child
that was beaten beaten with sticks is it
discussed in school
president Trump buying the they did they
talk about it in school and what are the
kids think what are the young people
think let's bake a joke to everybody
really that's not a big joke that's why
I'm here you think I flew 6,000 miles
for a big joke I think that's exactly
what
[Applause]